thank you
foreign
how are you guys doing we have a new
first minister of Scotland yes a new
first Minister who is of mixed Heritage
actually he's from joint Pakistani and
Kenyan mixed heritage heritage his name
is hamzu Yusuf no not the Hamza Yusuf
maybe you're aware of online from zetuna
college in America who speaks about
Islam No this is another Hamza Yusuf uh
this particular Hamza Yusuf however he
is supposedly meant to be a Muslim
unfortunately I have come across a very
disturbing interview of his where he was
talking about something which is
something which is known unequivocally
in the religion of necessity let's take
a look at the interview and come back
and respond in kind the question was do
you believe that gay sex is a sin
no if I can just be clear about that
that's not it's not I just have been
asked a question about 25 times and I've
answered it the same way 25 times so I I
can't change what's in certain faiths I
can't change what's in scripture while I
can tell you is the approach that I will
take which is that I will not allow
personal faith to be the basis of
legislation now at the end of the
interview she asked him Point Blank
unequivocally unambiguously is it a sin
and he said no this is
this is something which takes somebody
out of the religion of Islam you cannot
maintain a subscription to Islam if you
want to call it that you cannot be a
Muslim and say this at the same time
this is a negata of Islam this is and
negating every key verse or verses many
verses and a Hadith a plethora
multiplicity of different ahadis in the
Quran and in the Sunnah this takes you
out of the religion of Islam
what kind of verses are we talking about
for example in chapter 7 verse 1881
while Allah mentions
I mean
foreign
[Music]
that you are doing something elude
action that people haven't done before
you
you are approaching men with lust in a
sexual sexual manner this is so clear
mind
aside from women aside from women this
is talking about homosexuality clearly
yes
you are a transgressing people this is
what the Quran States unequivocally
there is no abrogation of this there's
nothing of this this is in the Quran
it's clear crystal clear it's Cutthroat
you have said two things in that
interview hanza yeah you said number one
I believe it's not a sin
okay and I can't change scripture by not
changing scripture the implication is
that you understand what is in the
scripture because the scripture says
what I've just mentioned to you so you
understand what's in the scripture you
cannot change it meaning what you've
done as much as you can possibly do this
is the messaging that you this is such a
weak pathetic messaging and to be honest
with you it's taking you out of the fold
of Islam
frankly there's no excuse the only thing
you can do is repentance you can say
it's
the Quran says you have to Toba you have
to rectify yourself and then you have to
clarify this matter in front of the
public you being in political office is
no it is no excuse at all for committing
and you know what's interesting about
this
I was watching
um before I watched this interview
between Piers Morgan and Jacob Reese MOG
and this individual he's a Catholic he
was asked directly very similar
questions he is a high a big player in
the conservative party I think they were
even mentioning his name he was one of
the major names main names that were
mentioned to be the next leader after
Boris Johnson stepped down this guy is a
is a big player in the conservative
party a big part of the cabinet but of
the executive form of government and
look he had more fortitude than you did
he had more authenticity than you did he
spoke the truth
of the matter and when he was asked
let's take a look at some of the things
he said um what are your views on
same-sex marriage is that something you
support I'm a Catholic and I take the
teaching of the Catholic Church
seriously married
um but marriage is a Sacrament and the
decision of what is a Sacrament lies
with the church not with Parliament can
I can I just establish do you oppose I
support the teacher of the Catholic
church it's a straight question whether
you think it's a sin I think I've
answered the straight question that is
that the teaching of the church in
matters of faith and morals uh is
authoritative so if he could do it why
couldn't you do it you coward you are a
coward you are a coward you are a cafer
as well you are a disbeliever of Allah
and the messenger in the Quran you are
not you have no right to call yourself a
Muslim you have you are excommunicated
from the religion of in Islam you are
out you're finished you are done that's
all I have to say about you and if you
want to come back to Islam you have to
take back your statement because you and
nobody else on the Facebook of the
planet can take part of the book and
reject part of the effort
attack foreign
that you take parts of the book and
reject parts of the book Ramadan and
fasting you take that part because it
has no problem no qualms
with what the white man wants you're
talking about white people in in
Parliament he was looking this person is
white this let's see the clip if we can
get the clip it's okay this person is
white this person is white this person
take my portfolio alone
the Lord president wait the Lord Justice
clerk white every high court judge white
the Lord Advocate white this Leicester
General white the chief Constable white
the white man we just we just saw here
who's a conservative and a Catholic has
more fortitude than you he represents us
more than you do on these issues so what
are you talking why are you well the
white man this and the white man that as
if you're some kind of anti-colonial
person you're not an anti-colonialist
you are you have the most colonized mind
of all of us you are an Uncle Tom Hamza
you are an uncle you are finished you're
done do you understand the only way back
is for you to make repentance and
clarification otherwise you will be
relegated to the trash Heap the Dustbin
of History you are just another Uncle
Tom just another just another
boy whatever her name is yeah you're
just another one of those people which
you're nothing you understand if you
want to be a real man you come out with
your beliefs and you go into an office
like that otherwise you're nothing and
you are nothing because you have left
the religion level in Islam and the only
way back is for repentance and
clarification and this is a lesson to
all of us no matter what kind of
pressure we are put on that yeah and
what kind of Allure of the Dunya that we
may have
you can never sell out your religion you
can never sell out your religion in this
very clear way you could have said
something which could have given you a
bit of could have allowed the
theological or the theologians to give
you some kind of wheel interpretive
scope but you were so clear-cut on the
matter that this is